see what happens here in game three well  we have a winner or will it be another  draw game two was dramatic between these  two  and I'm expecting an equally dramatic  game three jumping by the opening Choice  okay of the players it's another Berlin  but a very spicy version of the Berlin  and meanwhile exactly what we just  showed on the analysis board has  happened in this game so Prague has  found a way to trade off a set of Rooks  and eliminate Black's dangerous B Pawn  next move when the Black Brooks runs  away to safety white will simply capture  two pawns up  we know prague's very good in the end  game yeah  yeah my majority just drops the black  rook and that will end the game slightly  prematurely but uh it won't change the  result manager of shaking his head hung  a rook dropped that piece and Prague  takes the win impressive stuff by the  young Indian he makes a comeback the  match is now tied and we will see a game  four starting in